when the truly award last year and for
my book called Mamillius inches
intellectual background so i can show
you the the cover here this is what it
is and so I was unbelievably excited to
win that I mean first of all because i
think it's just fantastic that you know
colombia has this book award that is
given by students but then also because
having this skyman ilyas it was a poet
who about 2,000 years ago and wrote a
very sort of difficult poem about
astrology so even within classics this
is quite sort of obscure you know I made
it sound like virtue or Ovid you know
who I've worked on also but it was
really quite I mean this is the first
sort of real long graph in English about
this guy and so it's really not a sort
of mainstream topic and you know while I
was working on this I you know you come
classicists that sometimes get this like
are you moving on medallions it so I was
just like super excited that you know
students you know gave this the award
for the best faculty book of the year so
that was fantastic